foreign
hello and welcome to this session on
seeing the whole picture by unifying
operational data with analytics DSN 203
I'm German Yang senior engineering
manager on spanner a fully managed
relational database with unlimited scale
on Google cloud with me today we have
Jay Richardson VP of application
delivery at DaVita who will share their
Journey with Google Cloud databases
today we'll first cover why we need to
unify operational data with analytical
data and will invite Davida to walk us
through how they put that into action
and finally we will cover some exciting
launches in this area
a few years ago Garnet combined the
analytical database quadrant with the
operational dbms quadrant citing that
the market is converging and that is
indeed what we're seeing as well
we see a growth in the need for near
real-time insights where customers need
to make quick decisions from their
latest data the data is collected by the
operational databases then aggregate it
with historical information stored in
analytical databases and they are joined
to derive insights to drive business
decisions
some customers even incorporate AI
recommendations to further bolster their
data-driven decisions
let's talk about some real world use
cases where this comes to life in
banking a loan processing system can
determine in near real time the risk of
default so the application is
automatically routed to the right
approval workflow to ensure rapid
response to customers while protecting
the bank in retail a payment processing
system includes fraud detection in its
workflow to identify fraudulent
transactions in near real time as the
transaction is being processed the
system will flag high risk transactions
for additional processing or human
scrutiny based on the risk and potential
impact this can save retailers and
financial institutions up to hundreds of
millions of dollars every year
in health care users employ machine
learning to help in areas such as
predicting diseases like diabetes even
as part of a mobile clinic visit for the
underserved it can also identify the
best candidates for clinical trials or
even the mundane but important
administrative tasks that take up
roughly a quarter of the U.S nurses time
speaking of Health Care let's take a
look at what we've just covered in
practice I'm honored to have Jay
Richardson vice president of application
delivery at DaVita with me here today to
walk you through how the DaVita team
managed to combine operational data with
analytics on Google Cloud to upgrade
their clinics and patients experiences
over to UJ
thanks Doreen I want to talk a little
bit today about our company and what we
do if you're in the uh dialysis space
you probably know us if not um in the
provider space maybe you do we are one
of the largest kidney care companies in
the world and we really span the gamut
of Kidney Care from uh CKD which is
chronic kidney disease all the way
through treatment in our facility or at
home or and hopefully to a transplant
it's in our name Loosely translated of
giving life
and we are a very patient-centric
organization and so what I like about
technology and really I'm going to talk
about today is how you can use
technology and Innovation to directly
influence patient outcomes
and more specifically we're going to
highlight one of our core digital
transformation programs called Center
Without Walls and while I refer to it as
our clinical OS most people would call
out a an EHR electronic health record
but it's our take in a very dialysis
specific version of that
so as you can see on the left see wow is
now we're actively deploying and so if I
look back at some of the engineering
challenges that we've had anytime you do
something with this scale
and keeping in mind that most ehrs are
local so think about a clinic or maybe a
series of hospitals what we wanted to do
is to be able to take all of our data
and centralize it
that was a big big engineering challenge
for us so if you look at it at 600 000
treatments on 200 000 patients 45 000
clinicians and really all of the related
care activities in a centralized system
if we're going to go through that effort
kind of the next engineering challenge
was how do you improve insights without
sacrificing performance so how do we
take this centralized data actually do
something with it that improves the
patient outcome
thirdly if you're looking at
um
what where most ehrs fail or the
negative knocks I think on a lot of ehrs
is they're too task driven so we wanted
to take these insights and embed them
and really embed the complicated task
was when they were needed to be done
whether it was that day that week or
that month and we didn't want to
interfere with the quality of care so
again
the right information at the right time
was very important to us and then lastly
if we look at
another goal of the system is how do we
save clinicians time
so in any goal of transformation
especially inside Healthcare it should
be how do we save clinicians time so
they can get back to caring for what the
for their patients which is really you
know what fulfills the clinicians
so our partnership with Google and I
would say it started kind of at the
Grassroots we partnered on three main
areas so first is how do you take an
on-prem solution that was in the middle
of development and move it to gcp so if
we're looking through that we started
with spanner first and then normally
this wouldn't be what you start with uh
with a brand new Cloud agreement or a
brand new Cloud partnership but we did
and we were very successful with it with
Google's help and then everyone kind of
leaning all in so that was the spanner
component of it if we looked at next
with our design there with spanner to
make it super scalable we went with
domain but then as we started building
out more and more of the applications we
found that these cross-cutting concerns
were really a challenge for us and so
then we partnered with Google to
implement bigquery as our data warehouse
and then last but not least over the
last few months and and even we were on
it before uh we were the first customers
on it I believe in May from a gr
standpoint as we partnered with Google
uh to implement change streams and what
this allows us to to do is to replicate
changes out of spanner into BQ almost
real time and us for it to be able to
embed the analytics or you hear me kind
of switch between analytics and insights
into the actual workflow versus making
them a separate application
on the architecture front
um this sounds really complicated if you
look at it but I think the one thing I
would take away
this is uh if you're using the services
for spanner and change streams and BQ
you can really simplify what you have to
do as a Technology Group again it kind
of data flows here left to right from a
spanner replicated very quickly to PQ we
write Services over the top of the whole
ecosystem so this is more of our back
end picture and we could get a lot more
detail but in this one will stay pretty
high level
so this is what I always look for out of
one of these sessions so why would you
adopt these three pieces of Technology
so one is for scale and if you look at
it 45 000 users again those numbers are
not much for a bank but for us and
giving the criticality of this data
those numbers were pretty daunting for
on-prem we also wanted the ability to
scale currently we're launching around
100 clinics per week and that equates to
several thousand clinicians sometimes
and up to three or four thousand
patients migrating onto the platform per
week change streams kind of highlighting
it here in the middle and it's one of
those engineering wins that you rarely
get you get to improve speed you get to
make it more scalable and you get to run
it at a lower cost and so kind of
highlight that as we were able to take
replication that we were doing on our
own it was taking around 60 seconds and
really Baseline it from replication to
spanner to BQ in around 15 seconds we
also gained pretty much infinite
scalability so spanner will scale your
chain streams will scale I think kind of
the last column I'll look at and and
really point out the why so why did we
go through this journey with Google why
do we partner with them it's really
these insights and so be able to join
the data together and be able to provide
the right data at the right time to not
over overwhelm our clinicians with data
and then kind of a side benefit is we
get to do full aggregations for our key
patient meds and Labs data and on top of
that we have amazing performance for
these cross domain interfaces that are
very data Rich again I'd like to say
thank you for the partnership with
Google and all the people here at DaVita
thank you so much Jay for sharing the
video story and we're so happy to
partner with Davida to bring these
patient 360 views to provide better care
it's a summary of why combining
operational and analytical data was
previously a challenge first
technologies that tightly couple storage
and compute means that scaling becomes
very difficult second running analytical
queries on operational databases may
impact the performance of the customer's
Mission critical transactional workflows
and third it's pretty expensive
using Solutions like change streams and
data stream on Google Cloud we now have
a solution to these challenges
let's take a look at some new
capabilities in this area
we recently announced data stream for
bigquery which enables continuous
real-time replication from data from
operational databases such as MySQL
postgres SQL and Oracle into bigquery
Data stream for bigquery was developed
in close partnership with our bigquery
team and delivers a truly unique
seamless and easy to use experience that
enables near real-time insights in bit
query with just a few steps using
bigquery's newly developed change data
capture CDC functionality data stream
efficiently replicates updates directly
from Source systems into bigquery tables
in real time
you no longer have to waste valuable
resources building and managing complex
data pipelines just configure your
Source database connection type and
destination in bigquery and you're all
set
data stream for bigquery will backfill
historical data and continuously
replicate new changes as they happen and
as data schemas database schemas shift
data streams seamlessly handle schema
changes and automatically as new tables
and columns into bigquery
continuing with the replication story we
are thrilled to announce that bigtable
change streams is now in preview
bigtable change streams allows customers
to track changes within their database
based on their configuration and to
access and integrate this data with
other systems this means customers can
efficiently replicate data to data
warehouses like bigquery for analytics
build event-driven applications by
triggering Downstream Behavior or
synchronize changes to enable
multi-cloud Downstream deployments
bigtable chain streams tracks data
rights updates and deletes changes are
synchronously written along with the
data and you can stream out the changes
in real time for many use cases we
provide TurnKey connectors but you can
also write custom processing pipelines
using our chain streams data flow
connector will have even more
flexibility and control integrating with
the bigtable API directly
as a refresher Cloud spanner change
streams has been in GA since May this
year and is what David uses to power
their dashboards Spanish handstreams
enables customers to track changes
within their database based on their
configuration and to access and
integrate this data with other systems
this means customers like Devita can
easily replicate database changes to
bigquery for analytics trigger
Downstream application behaviors such as
through Pub sub or capture database
changes for auditing or archival in GCS
and finally for customers who want to
incorporate AI into their data-driven
decision-making process we are happy to
announce the preview for vertex AI
integration for model serving in Cloud
spanner built-in integration with vertex
AI unifies operational databases with AI
making it simpler to consume published
machine learning models and build
ai-powered applications faster as shown
in the sample retail checkout process
where fraud detection is part of the
same database transaction and the
appropriate action is taken as part of
the checkout process this is just a few
lines of SQL to register the vertex AI
model and to run the model using the ml
predict function
there is a lot more exciting content at
next and I encourage you to attend the
sessions to learn more about our spanner
bigtable and data stream products for
spanner we recently launched free trial
instances so you can now try spanner out
for free to get your feet wet take a
look at our quick Labs tutorials
and with that we have come through the
end of our session thank you for
listening and we look forward to hearing
from you on our new features
foreign